let me go next to our caller from the
3:05 area code who's calling today from
3:05
hi David greatly appreciate your work
quick question
so if Sanders is not the nominee you
know with whatever happens in the
convention right what would happen if
the swell of people just do agree to do
a brighten in our ballots is that I
don't want to hinder you know democracy
but I think what's happening now is
hindering democracy and I just want to
try to you know support him as much as
possible and that's my question is it
possible you know and what would happen
are you saying if people write Bernie in
in November even if he's not the nominee
correct that would almost guarantee
Trump is reelected now you may see it as
a means to an end you may want to do it
anyway but mathematically that's what it
would lead to if there were significant
numbers of people writing Bernie in as
an independent instead of voting voting
for whoever the nominee is they would
probably get trump reelected right all
right all right no problem
appreciate the phone call let's go next
to our caller from the six one seven
area code six one seven possibly a
caller here in Boston what's going on
six one seven
hi David this is a calling from JP
Boston
hey Andrew what's up yeah so gives my
overall question as a Massachusetts
resident I'm obviously really bummed out
about how the results came to be and you
know being like many others thought
Bernie was going to win and you know I
know that you're no campaign strategist
but I'm just trying to think you know
what Bernie came to Massachusetts he
went to Springfield and then Boston
would get a sense to major cities
however he didn't go to Worcester which
I'm just kind of I guess I'm wondering
because Worcester is like the second
most populous city in the New England
area if he were to have campaigned in
Worcester as well would that have really
made much of a difference you think no I
don't think listen here's the thing what
happened on Super Tuesday was a national
phenomenon
right so you could say well
Burnie had gone and campaigned in
Worcester he might have gotten an
additional delegate in Massachusetts but
then it's zero-sum so in order to go to
Worcester he would have had to not go
somewhere in Texas and maybe he would
have had what one less delegate there
one fewer delegate or you know just pick
a place where Bernie went he would have
had to go to Worcester instead of that
other place and what you saw in Super
Tuesday was a combi it was a National
momentum for Joe Biden it was South
Carolina he did better than expected
heat drops out
aimée drops out they endorsed by didn't
it becomes clear what the options are
and so no one won rally in Worcester
would not likely have turned
Massachusetts to Bernie and again even
if it did because it's all proportional
delegate allotments he might have gotten
an extra delegate or two here but lost a
delegate or two elsewhere that he had to
skip a rally I'd say yeah that makes
sense
um all right well yeah thank you for
answering my call all right Andrew great
to hear from you let's take a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we'll go right back to the
phone's momentarily